I think I know your answer to this but
let's let's test it because I think you
you're going to be wrong
so there's a robot behind you do you
think there will be a time in the future
when it will be unethical and illegal to
kill a robot because they will have
sentience
my guess is you would say no legs
there's because there's a fundamental
difference between humans and robots and
I just want to get you on record because
I think you'll be wrong
um I mean it depends on the level of
development I would assume of of the
robots I mean you're assuming a
complexity in the robots that that
eventually imitates what we in the
religious life would call the human soul
yes the ability to choose freely for
example yes which I believe is sort of
the capacity for uh for human beings the
ability to suffer yeah if if all of that
could
be
proved and not programmed meaning the
freely willed capacity of a machine to
do
X Y or Z you could you could not
pinpoint exactly where it happens in the
program right yeah it's not
deterministic yeah
um then it would raise serious moral
issues for sure I'm not trying to answer
that question are you afraid of that
time I'm not sure I'm afraid of that
time I mean it's
any more than I'd be afraid if aliens
arrived on in in the world and had these
characteristics well there's just a lot
of moral complexities and they don't
necessarily have to be in the physical
space they can be in the digital space
uh there's an increased sophistication
and number of bots on the internet
including on Twitter uh as they become
more and more intelligent there's going
to be serious questions about what is
our moral duty to protect ones that have
or claimed to have an identity and
that'll be really interesting actually
what I'm afraid of is the opposite
happening meaning that people the word
the worst that should happen is that we
develop robots So Sophisticated that
they appear to have free will and then
we treat them with human dignity that
should be the worst that happens what
I'm afraid of is the opposite is that
that we if if we're talking about this
particular hypothetical that we develop
robots that have all of these apparent
abilities and then we dehumanize them
which leads us to also dehumanize the
other humans around us which you could
easily see happening the devaluation of
life to the point where it doesn't
really matter I mean people have always
treated unfortunately newly discovered
other humans this way so I I don't think
there's actually a new problem I think
it's a it's a pretty old problem it'll
just be interesting when it's made of
human hands yeah it's uh it's it's an
opportunity to celebrate Humanity or to
um
to bring out the worst in humanity uh so
the derision that naturally happens like
you said with pointing out the other